we all know that Bitcoin has been
extremely correlated to stocks and
broader equities over the last few
months and we now have a break in that
correlation to some degree and if it
does happen like we are saying that it
might be happening you better strap in
we have a chart here showing how the s p
has trended over the last few months
from January until now June the S P 500
is down 13.3 percent in total but as
Bitcoin has been down tremendously also
the s p has gone upward over the last
few days and it looks like it is now
breaking from that correlation to some
degree to the upside that Bitcoin has
been in so we have a tweet here from
Justin Bennett he says Bitcoin has been
positively correlated with the S P 500
for some time now the s p had an
impressive rally last week while Bitcoin
was still sleeping snoozing looks like
BTC is about to play catch-up this would
put it in the mid 30 range at the
current s p levels and he's got a nice
little chart down here with the arrow
for those that aren't as educated shows
you up and to the right baby blue is
Bitcoin the red or the orange there is
the S P 500 so basically what he's
saying is that the s p has been
correlated to bitcoin for the last few
months at least since January and as the
s p has broken to the upside he expects
to some degree if that correlation stays
for Bitcoin to do the same now as
Bitcoin as we all realize this hasn't
always been the case Bitcoin has been
trading in correlation but that is not
what always happens this may or may not
take place trade at your own risk but I
do think it is an interesting narrative
given what we've seen one at the
correlation level but two with the s p
over the last week so we have some more
uh charts here I think that show exactly
what has been happening uh from a
correlation point with Bitcoin relative
to uh gold the S P 500 ethereum bonds
Etc and uh they they show exactly what
we're talking about right which is that
Bitcoin has been correlated to a bunch
of different assets over the last few
months which weren't necessarily the
case beforehand and now it has been so
there's much there's people that are
much smarter than me that maybe have
shown uh that it may not be correlated
to that degree going forward but for the
time being we will see what happened
John what do you think about this yeah
there's the chart thing here we go
that's 20 21. that's 2021 you can see
the correlation obviously ethereum a
smaller market cap coin outperformed
Bitcoin in 2021 during those bull runs
uh but everything else was kind of
bouncing between uh correlation
uncorrelated so that point to
um to negative point two is kind of that
range that they see the correlation in
um and then obviously the correlation is
literally just how much did one go up
versus what was it supposed to or what
does it normally do and then what about
another asset and that's how they find
that correlation
yeah this is a an interesting chart here
obviously because at some point they all
cross kind of in the middle and then
they all they head separate ways uh but
the Bitcoin part is more interesting to
me because Bitcoin has always had that
narrative where it's a non-correlated
asset right that has appreciated well
over the last decade even on a
volatility adjusted basis if you look at
the sharp ratio over two years five
years ten years Etc it's still
outperforming most of these other uh
stocks bonds Etc real estate whatever it
might be because of that volatility the
upside because of that asymmetry that it
has represented so as we get into higher
number Nows and higher market cap
Bitcoin is over a trillion dollar market
cap right now we're at six something uh
so you get to this point where while it
may be moving in tandem I still do not
think that's the narrative right
institutional flows have driven
bitcoin's price over the the last year
at least two years and what we're seeing
now is with the FED in a difficult place
at least here in the United States it's
very difficult for a lot of these
institutional shops not to treat it like
a risk asset that's exactly what they're
doing right there it's trading downward
with stocks it's trading down with other
risk assets people are selling across so
where does that decoupling happening
there's certainly been evidence that
I've seen in the past of like a Time
time period where maybe it Trends in
that way for three months six months Etc
will Clemente comes on the show all the
time the wizard talking about how this
may eventually change and what the level
of Bitcoin would have to hit for it to
reverse in that direction I don't think
it's going to stay correlated to the S P
500 for a longer period of time but it
is interesting to track over the last
three four five months how correlated it
has been and what a move in the S P 500
now to the upside might mean for Bitcoin
yeah I think over time though it will
get uncorrelated and this is just my
personal opinion but right now we're
gonna see the correlation just simply
off because people are treating it like
a risk asset and the big players are
treated like a risk asset right so when
you need cash
um or you need to get out of a trade
that you may not necessarily have a ton
of conviction in this is the time right
people have been selling for the last
six uh six to seven months now at this
point uh trying to get at a certain
assets trying to at least have some
liquidity in their portfolio and be able
to deploy cash when they see fit when
they see opportunity
um and I think that's what people are
doing with Bitcoin they're doing it with
stocks as well uh maybe some you know
some wash trading what's happening at
the end of the year as well they didn't
buy as much as they sold or whatever it
is
um but couldn't we've seen a massive
price decline and I think that's just
based off the broader idea and macro
environment of hey we're selling off
assets we need liquidity we need cash um
in our reserves this is good for Traders
this is good for Traders but this is
part of the reason why I don't really
look at a lot of this stuff because
that's an interesting observation you
know the the person made the tweet and
showed on the chart hey look we may have
five percent to the upside 10 to the
upside whatever it might be but at the
end of the day there's different types
of investors right you can be a Trader
or you can be a long-term investor and
just dollar cost average in an asset
holder for a long period of time and I'm
the latter right which means that I
don't really look at those charts and
get super excited because maybe there's
some volatility in the in the time being
to the upside where you can gain five
six seven percent and a Trader would get
excited about that due to technical
levels or kind of where they see the
price going but ultimately that doesn't
make a huge difference to me right your
dollar cost averaging over a long time
period and you're holding this asset
planning to hold it at least for the
next five years 10 years 50 years and
that ultimately takes away a lot of
these decisions around having to worry
about the price on it I don't even check
the price most of it yeah right like I
just know that sure it's in this range
is trading people are talking about all
these things but when you're in a market
like this where it's trading
directionally for a long period of time
it's much easier to be in a position
like this where you're just continuing
to do exactly what you do you know days
are going by you're buying more Bitcoin
you're buying more Bitcoin you're buying
more Bitcoin and you're not necessarily
worried about oh maybe it goes up five
percent tomorrow like I should try to
trade that I don't really have any
interest in doing that there are certain
people that are good at it I just know
I'm not one of them so my general advice
around this kind of stuff is like know
what you're good at know what you're not
good at know what you're optimizing for
and what you're trying to do long term
and then attack it from that standpoint
like that stat is probably helpful to
some people but to me it doesn't really
matter all that much I agree completely
and one thing I do is I'm super
um
I'm I'm terrible Gambler terrible day
trader like terrible trying to time the
market and one of the best investment
principles that have that has done well
for me is just time in the market not
timing the market right and just being
invested in a asset that you believe in
over long tail over a long time period
whether that is Apple stock Amazon stock
Netflix stock like doesn't matter if
it's an equity a commodity like gold or
silver or even uh crypto like Bitcoin
right it doesn't really matter as long
as you have a long tail conviction and
you actually have that conviction so
when you see those 80 drawdowns 40 50 in
stocks now you still hold it and you may
even buy more hey you did you like this
video great we make five of them a day
and post them here on this channel make
sure you subscribe like the video and
see you next time